Bitte schön.
Okay.
Schönen guten Tag.
Ich heiße Doktor Günes.
Ich bin hier auf der Station Assistenz aus Tätig.
Ich würde gerne das Anruf Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja.
So, so erst möchte ich Ihren persönlichen Daten dokumentieren.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Patrizia Eisenwood.
Wie schreibt man Ihre Namen und Nachname?
Patrizia, P-A-T-R-I-Z-I-A.
Patrizia, ich bin eine Frau.
Okay, und Nachname?
Eisenwood, E-I-S-E-N-H-U-T.
Ja, vielen Dank Frau Eisenwood.
Wie alt sind Sie denn?
Ich bin 32 Jahre.
32?
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
14. Mai 1992.
Super.
Frau Eisenwood, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 m.
Ja, und wie viel Regen Sie so seit?
60 kg.
Okay, Frau Eisenwood, was will Sie uns beschwerden?
Ja, ich bin ungefähr 3 Wochen, wenn ich sehr müde habe,
Fieber und wenn Schlapp schnell erschöpft,
habe auch Luftnot und der Puls ist schnell.
Ja, es geht nicht gut.
Herrsrasen und Luftnot haben Sie auch.
Ja, und ich bin so müde, wenn man so schnell erschöpft.
Okay.
Frau Eisenwood, seid bereit, wo Sie diese Beschwerden haben?
Ja.
Haben Sie ihr Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe Räuchiger gemessen, das ist bis 39.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Es ist sehr unangenehm für Sie.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich bin einfach nur müde, schlapp kaputt.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie Sie Kraftlosigkeit auch?
Ja, ja, Kraftlos schlapp, kann ich mir richtig belasten.
Was geht nicht mehr?
Okay.
Frau Eisenwood, Ihre Beschwerden haben Sie plötzlich oder langsam angefangen?
Sie sind langsam angefangen.
Haben Sie schon an diese Beschwerden erlebt?
Nein, sowas habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Frau Eisenwood, schlafen Sie gut?
Ich bin immer müde.
In letzter Zeit, in den letzten Wochen, vorher habe ich immer gut geschlafen.
Aber in den letzten Wochen bin ich immer müde,
ich habe mich oft über die Nacht nachschlafen.
Ich habe mich oft über die Nacht nachschlafen.
Okay.
Leiden Sie nach Schweiß?
Ja.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
In letzter Zeit nicht mehr gut.
Ich habe auch kein großes Hungergefühl.
Früher habe ich besser gegessen.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe Gewicht abgenommen.
So vier Kino schätze ich innerhalb der letzten vier Wochen.
Drei Wochen.
Innerhalb drei Wochen.
Okay.
Leiden Sie auch an Schüttelfrost?
Nein, Schüttelfrost nicht.
Ich habe die Schüttelfrost- und Schwiessen.
Das habe ich, wie gesagt, die Müdigkeit und Lustnot.
Schnell.
Haben Sie eine Körpertemperatur im Mund gemessen?
Ja, im Mund.
Haben Sie dagegen noch etwas eingenommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nichts dagegen eingenommen.
Ich wollte irgendwann wissen, woher kommt das wieder?
Okay, ja.
Es ist sehr unangenehm für Sie sein.
Frau Eisenholt, ich wollte nachfragen,
leiden Sie an chronische Vererkrankungen,
wie zum Beispiel Blutzucker, Bluthochdruck?
Ich habe eine chronische Schilddrüsenentzündung.
Schon seit ungefähr, ja, mindestens seit 15 Jahren.
Ist das bekannt?
Und das ist auch, war Anfangs auch,
eine leichte Unterfunktion.
Aber ich nehme jetzt ein Medikament ein.
Und darunter sind die Blutwerte in Ordnung.
Aber es muss immer kontrolliert werden.
Ärzte sagen, das sei eine chronische Schilddrüsenentzündung,
eine Autoimmunerkrankung.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Das Mittel heißt Ultirox.
Ultirox 50 steht dahinter.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens ein.
Okay.
Ich habe mich noch seit ungefähr 18 Jahren
eine Milchzucker-Unverträglichkeit.
Ich hatte früher häufig Bauchschmerzen und Blähungen.
Und dann hat man das untersucht.
Und dann hat man gefunden,
dass ich Milchzucker nicht gut vertrage.
Und seitdem halte ich mich von der Ernährung her.
Aber dementsprechend meide diese Haungsmittel,
die viel Milchzucker enthalten.
Und seitdem geht es mir aber echt gut damit.
Da habe ich diese Beschwerden nicht mehr.
Und ich habe eine Nickel-Alargie gegen Nickel.
Was oisert Sie hier, Nickel-Alargie?
Ja, das bekomme ich dann Exem und Ausschlag.
An den Stellen, wo ich Nickel hatte,
also beim Gürtel, an den Gürtelschnallen und am Knöpfen.
Und jetzt weiß ich das.
Und dann habe ich jetzt nichts mehr aus Nickel.
Okay.
Ansonsten leiden Sie weitere Unverträglichkeiten
oder gründliche Erkrankungen?
Nehmen Sie noch etwas regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Nein, ich nehme sonst nichts ein.
Nur das Mittel für die Schildröße.
Okay.
Ist das schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als kleines Kind wurde bei mir festgestellt,
dass ich zu viel Hirnwasser im Gehirn habe.
Da wurde dann ein Schlauch gelegt aus dem Kopf
unter der Haut durch in den Bauchern.
Da leuten das Hirnwasser ab.
Und das war rechtzeitig erkannt worden.
Und das wurde als Kleinkind gemacht.
Und da waren die Untersuchungen bisher alle gut.
Das Erzgeg ist erledigt, glaube ich.
Mit 10 Jahren, malter von 10 Jahren,
wurde ich am Blindterm operiert
und malter von 12 Jahren an den Mandeln.
Ja, in der Kindheit, meinen Sie, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie Frau Eisenhut?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay.
Grima.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig oder geregentlik Alkohol?
Nicht regelmäßig, gelegentlich.
Vielleicht so zweimal, zwei Glas Wein in pro Woche.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie bitte folgende Frage.
Nicht persönlich, das ist eine ultimative Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Grima.
Frau Eisenhut, leiden Ihre Erten an chronische Erkrankungen,
z.B. Blutzucker Erkrankheiten oder Krebskrankheiten?
Mein Vater, in der er ist 66 Jahre alt,
er leidet so seit zwei oder drei Jahren,
ich weiß nicht mehr genau, an Leukämie.
Das muss immer kontrolliert werden
und im Umblick sind die Werte erhöht,
die weißen Blutkabbelchen aber stabil.
Aber er muss da regelmäßig das Blutbild kontrollieren lassen.
Und dann hat er noch seit einigen Jahren Bluthochdruck,
man nimmt der Medikament, aber ich weiß nicht, welche.
Die Mutter, die ist 66 Jahre alt,
hat eine chronische Bauchspeichodrysenentzündung.
Man kennt die Ursache nicht, sie trinkt kein Alkohol,
aber sie hatte jetzt schon mehrfach Bauchspeichodrysenentzündungen
und das ist immer sehr schmerzhaft.
Die Ärzte sagen, sie hatte jetzt eine chronische Bauchspeichodrysenentzündung
und hat jetzt auch etwas Zucker dadurch bekommen,
weil die Bauchspeichodryse nicht mehr so richtig arbeiten kann.
Okay, waren Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist 34 Jahre alt,
der hatte ein Alter vor 18 Jahren, hatte er,
ich muss erst mal gucken, ob ich das richtig verkaust,
ich spreche Lymphogranulomatose.
Hat er.
Aber das war damals gut behandelt worden
und es geht ihm gut.
Er ist da immer regelmäßig zur Nachtsorge untersucht und gegangen,
aber bisher ist das alles gut.
Nehmt er, regiert er sich Medikamente ein?
Nein, und Rodenblick nimmt er nichts an.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Ich bin in einem Schulle.
In einem Gymnasium.
Haben Sie viel Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Alltag?
Die Schule ist sehr anstrengend.
Das ist so.
Aber ich kann mich immer wieder ganz gut auch erholen
und das macht mir weiterhin Spaß.
Es ist anstrengend.
Okay, richtig.
Frau Eisenholt,
haben Sie Kinder und sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Ich bin auch nicht verheiratet.
Ich habe einen Partner,
Lebenspartner.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Lebenspartner zusammen?
Ja.
Frau Eisenholt,
sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Vor drei Monaten war ich in Thailand und Cambodia.
Ich habe eine Erbrechen- und Durchfall-Infekt.
Ich musste die erforderlichen Medikamente nehmen.
Ich musste Malaria-Tabletten nehmen.
Die konnte ich drei Tage nicht nehmen.
Aber danach habe ich die wieder eingenommen.
Ich habe eine Erbrechen- und Durchfall-Infekt.
Ich war drei Wochen in Thailand und Cambodia.
Vor drei Monaten war die Reise.
Ich war drei Wochen dort.
drei Monate, okay.
Und haben Sie einen Bruchdurchfall gelitten?
Es war kein Blut, aber ich hatte, mir war drei Tage lang, war mir schlecht, ich musste erbrechen
und hatte Durchfall, das war drei Tage und danach ging es aber wieder gut.
Aber es hatten einige aus unserer Reisegruppe ähnliche Probleme.
Und haben Sie ein Glück gegen Malaria etwas eingenommen?
Das habe ich gemacht, das hatte mir vorher der Arzt verschrieben, wo ich war, der Turbemiliziner,
der mich auch für alles geimpft hatte vorher.
Wie gesagt, drei Tage habe ich diese Tablette nicht genommen, weil der war so schlecht
und ich habe ja alles wieder ausgebrochen.
Okay, nach der Reise, haben Sie diese Beschwerden angefangen?
Nein, die Reise war ja vor drei Monaten gefasst, also vor zwei und ein halb Monaten.
Und jetzt meine Beschwerden haben ja erst vor drei Wochen angefangen.
Okay, ich möchte eine Zusammenfassung.
Sind Sie seit drei Wochen müde?
Sie haben Fieber, Sie fühlen sich schlapp und haben Sie auch Luftnot und Herzrasen?
Ja.
Haben Sie sonst noch etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe bemerkt, dass in den letzten 14 Tagen habe ich gemerkt, dass mein Hals irgendwie insgesamt dicker geworden ist.
Das ist so an der Seite hier, ich habe den Eindruck, das ist dicker geworden.
Ich habe eine Halskette, die liegt sonst immer sehr eng an, die kann ich jetzt gar nicht mehr zuschließen, weil die da nicht mehr passt.
Ja, okay, verstehe ich.
Sind Sie durcheschmerzhaft oder beweglich?
Nein, die wird ziemlich fest, ziemlich fest.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Frau Eisenhut, wir sind fast fertig, haben Sie noch Fragen an uns?
Ja, was kann das sein, was kann ich haben?
Macht mir der große Sorgen.
Ja, ich verstehe, ich resorge.
Frau Eisenhut, es ist so früh etwas genau zu sagen.
Ja.
Ich bitte Sie ein wenig geduld.
Wir müssen zuerst ein paar Untersuchungen, wie zum Beispiel körperliche Untersuchungen, Blutspiel und Bildgebändeverfahren durchführen.
Sobald wir alle Ergebnisse vorlegen haben, werde ich Ihrem Fall mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Dann werde ich Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren, was Sie genau haben.
Wir sind hier ein großes Team, ein erfahrenes Team und für Sie da machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorge, Sie sind in guten Händen.
Okay, gut.
Warten Sie bitte in den Untersuchungszimmer, ich komme gleich.
Okay, danke.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt ja etwas Zeit, denken Sie an die Fachbegriffe, Fachbegriffe für Luftnot, Fachbegriffe für fieberhafte Temperaturen vielleicht,
Schweisse für Schwellen, für diese Dinge.
Und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die jetzt noch dabei sind, das sind eine ganze Menge, haben vielleicht noch Fragen.
Haben Fragen, Kollegen, noch andere?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie mir näher beschreiben, ist das Fieber dauerhaft oder gibt es auch Fieberfreitage oder Tagen?
Also, Fieberfreitage, glaube ich, habe ich bisher nicht gehabt.
Manchmal ist das Fieber morgens vielleicht bei 38 morgens, aber abends ist es meist 39.
Aber Fieberfreitage habe ich nicht beobachtet.
Waren Sie beim Hausarzt bevor der Reise oder haben Sie Ihren Hausarzt informiert über die Reise?
Hat er Ihnen Medikamente gegen Malaria verschrieben?
Ja, das habe ich auch schon eben gesagt.
Ich war beim Tropenmediziner und der Tropenmediziner hat mir noch ein paar Impfungen gegeben, wie es gefehlt haben, Hepatitis.
Und ich glaube, japanische Enzifalitis ist das und auch Malaria-Tabletten.
Die sollte ich ja auch nehmen, das habe ich auch gemacht.
Aber eben drei Tage lang habe ich die Tabletten nicht genommen in Cambodia, weil ich da so Durchfall unterbrechen musste.
Das wurde dann aber schnell besser und dann konnte ich wieder diese Tabletten nehmen.
Gibt es jemanden, die in ihrer Gebung, die da an ähnlichen Beschwerden leiden?
Damals, als wir mit der Reisegruppe in Cambodia waren, da waren noch zwei andere auch erkrankt mit Magendam-Problemen.
Aber auch das wurde bei dem besser, aber jetzt kenne ich hier niemanden, der so etwas hat.
Ich habe keine Informationen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Luftnot haben.
Haben Sie Gusten oder Ersteiger der Atemfröckerns?
Also, Gusten habe ich nicht.
Ich kenne auch gar nicht.
Aber ich merke eben, wir wohnen in einer Straße, wo es etwas ansteigt.
Da konnte ich früher immer ganz normal hochlaufen.
Aber jetzt fällt mir das sehr schwer.
Und ich musste auch zweimal anhalten, um zu Fuß zu unserem Haus zu kommen.
Und das kenne ich nicht.
Da habe ich Luftnot.
Da musste ich erst mal stehen bleiben.
Und dann brauche ich ein, zwei Minuten, um mich zu erholen.
Aber Schmerzen habe ich dabei nicht und auch keinen Gusten.
Wie lange haben Sie eine Leukämie?
Der Vater hat seit zwei Jahren eine Leukämie.
Er hat eine Leukämie, aber es wird immer kontrolliert.
Und im Augenblick sagen die Ärzte, das ist stabil.
Es geht ihm ganz gut damit.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden?
Ja, weil der Hals ist ja auch ein bisschen dick.
Ich muss sehr gut meine Nahrung kauen, damit ich schlucken kann.
Sonst fällt mir das etwas schwer.
Ist Ihnen eine Blase der Haut aufgefallen?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, danke.
Gut, vielleicht noch eine Frage aus meiner Sicht für die Stellen.
Die Frage nach aktuellen Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen.
Ist der Stuhlgang normal oder haben Sie Durchfall?
Nein, der Stuhlgang ist normal.
Ich mache einmal pro Tag Stuhlgang.
Da hat sich aber nichts geändert in letzter Zeit.
Und Wasserlassen ist auch in Ordnung.
Ich habe da keine Probleme.
Ich denke, die Fragen gestellt, Herr Oberarzt.
Können wir als Alske Schikri anfangen?
Wir auch gerne.
Ja, Ginesch.
Ja, schön guten Nachmittag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Haben Sie küsse Zeit, um den Patientin vorzustellen?
Ja, habe ich.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Patricia Eisenhut ist eine 32-jährige Patientin.
Sie stellte sich bei uns in der Notaufnahme
mit seit drei Wochen bestehenden Fatigue,
Asthenie, Adynami und erhöhte Körpertemperatur vor.
Sie leidete an erhöhten Körpertemperatur bis auf 39 Grad.
Im Mund gemessen, darüber hinaus klagte sie über Hyperhidrosis.
Sie haben in Appätenz die Sonne und als Symptomatik
Gewichtverlust von 4,5 Kilo.
Ja, von vier Wochen, drei Wochen.
Ja, okay.
Sehr gut.
Ich habe das jetzt aufgeführt.
Vielleicht ergänzend sagen Sie ruhig, es bestehen febrile Temperaturen.
Bis 39 Grad oral gemessen.
Ja, ja, alles super.
Danke.
Es ist sehr wichtig erwähnen ist, dass Sie seit letzten Tagen
Submandubila-Lampknoten bemerken haben.
Ja, ansonsten war die Nevegedetiv-Anamnese unauffällig.
Ja, die Patientin berichtet über servikale Schwellungen.
Wir wissen noch nicht, ob es Lymphknoten sind.
Ja, das ist vielleicht die Vermutung des Arztes.
Aber die Patientin berichtet über servikale Schwellungen
seit einigen Tagen oder Wochen verbunden mit dysphagie.
Ja, und recht schluckstörend.
Ja, genau.
An Vorerkrankungen berichtete sie seit 15 Jahren
an eine Hashimoto-Tiroiditis zu leiden.
Dagegen nimmt sie regelmäßig Ötrox 50 Mikrogramm morgens ein.
Ja.
Die anderen klackt sie über, dass sie seit ungefähr 18 Jahren
Laktosintoleranz gelitten habe.
18 Jahre besteht eine Laktoseintoleranz.
Was hat die Patientin noch als Kleinkind gehabt?
Ja, die Frage nach, wo Operationen ergab, eine Abendektomie
und eine Tronsylektomie in der Kindheit,
darüber hinaus, dass sich eine Schandoperationen wegen der
Hydrocele, ja.
Oder Hydrocephalus.
Ja, Hydrocephalus.
Als Kleinkind fand eine Schand-OP statt, wegen Hydrocephalus.
Diesbezüglich ist die Patientin unauffällig.
Also Hydrocephalus.
Hydrocele ist ja mehr, man kann eine Hydrocele,
ja zum Beispiel am Roten, haben.
Ja, das ist ein Wasserbruch, eine Wasseransammlung,
aber in diesem Falle, in Hirn oder in Schädel,
ein Hydrocephalus.
Ja.
Okay.
Gut.
Ich trinke nicht raucher, ich trinke geregentlich zwei
klasse Wein.
Der Drogonkonsum wurde der Patientin verneint.
Okay.
Familienanamnistisch fand sich beim Vater eine Lükemi
und eine Arterelle Hipertoni.
Ja.
Beide Mutter eine chronische Pankreatitis und Diabetes mellitus
tipsyvei.
Okay.
Ihr 34-jährige Bruder hat einen, hat eine Sarkozytis
gelitten.
Ja.
Lympho, Granulomatose, okay.
Ja, ist ja immer ein bisschen unverkürzt.
Man kann sagen, oder ein Sarkozytis.
Im Alter, nicht im Alter?
34.
Der ist jetzt 34, aber wie alt war der Bruder,
als er am 18. Lebensjahr war?
Ja, im Alter von 18 Jahren.
Okay.
Gut.
Gibt es noch ein wichtiges Informationen in der Vorgeschichte
der Patientin?
Ja.
Bereflich ist sie als Lehrerin in einer Gymnasium tätig.
Ist ledig.
Aber lebt mit ihrem Freund zusammen.
Sie hat viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Sie hat eine Nickelallergie bekannt,
die sich mit exantem Äußeren.
Ja.
Sie hat viel Stress.
Stuhl und Mikzio sind unauffällig.
Sie krackte über Meteorismus.
Das war aber vor einigen Jahren.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Es gibt noch eine wichtige ananästische Zeit.
Sie war vor drei Monaten in Thailand und Cambodia
in den Tropen.
Nach der Reise hatte sie eine Gastroenteritis.
Während der Reise.
Sie klackte über eine Gastroenteritis.
Ja, das war es.
Manelia, nach der Ergänzung.
Die Ergänzung wäre wichtig.
Aufgrund einer dreitägigen Gastroenteritis in Cambodia
konnte sie ihre Malaria-Pofilaxe nicht komplett
einnehmen.
Sie hat drei Tage einnehmen.
Ansonsten besteht ein kompletter Impfstatus
von Tropenmediziner, von Tropenarzt.
Zumindest für die Anamese.
Das ist wichtig,
gerade bei einem Status Februilis.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ananästische Angaben gehe ich von Verdacht auf eine akute Lykemi.
Die Differenz der Akustik kommt auch auf eine Malaria-Infektion
oder eine akute Lymphoma.
Ja, bin ich mit einverstanden.
Gut.
Ja, ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Sie haben das sehr ruhig gemacht.
Sie haben das systematisch gearbeitet.
Die Frage, wenige Fragen blieben offen, zum Beispiel Stuhlgang Wasserlassen.
Das wäre in diesem Zusammenhang sicherlich noch hilfreich,
das zu fragen.
Aber ansonsten haben Sie, denke ich, das sehr gut erfasst
und das ist eine gute Frage, die Sie auch immer geben.
Mit vielen Fachbegriffen, die Sie richtig genannt haben,
das fand ich sehr gut.
Es geht jetzt nicht um eine richtige Diagnose,
aber in eine richtige Richtung.
Verdacht auf Lymphom oder Verdacht auf akute Leukämie
in dem Alter, weniger eine chronische Leukämie
und differenzial diagnostisch bei der Reiseanamese,
sicherlich solange der Verdacht im Raum steht,
auch Verdacht auf malaria.
Das rieße sicher relativ einfach durch einen dicken Tropfen im Blut
auszuschließen oder beweisen.
Aber auf alle Fälle gehört diese differenzial diagnostische Überlegung
damit rein.
Ganz klar.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Wann machen Sie Ihre Prüfung?
1.9.
Da wäre ich ganz gelassen.
Das kriegen Sie gut hin.
Im Verdacht Diagnose Malalia oder Lycoma.
Ich würde vielleicht als erste Verdacht Diagnose
ein Lymphom oder eine Leukämie stellen.
Die Schwellungen zerkal im Hals,
diese B-Symptomatik, die angedeutete nicht ganz komplette
und natürlich die Malaria.
Aber ich habe bewusst zwei Dinge genommen,
die miteinander konkurrieren.
Aber in Kibersion seid ich nicht auffällig für die Malaria.
Ja, aber Sie können bis zu einem Jahr,
gibt es Fälle, dokumentiert,
dass bis zu einem Jahr eine Malaria entstehen kann.
Manche haben eben Durchfälle oder nur Durchfall.
Manche haben keinen Durchfall, manche haben nur Fieber.
Aber es gibt Fälle in der Reisemedizin,
Tropenmedizin, das weiß ich aus meiner Zeit damals,
wo ich da auch gearbeitet habe.
Dass es bis zu einem Jahr gehen kann,
weshalb muss man eine Reiseanamese ruhig sagen,
nicht nur in den letzten Wochen,
sondern ich würde ruhig sagen,
in den letzten 12 Monaten in den Tropen,
das ist richtig, sonst vergisst man das vielleicht.
Dann kann es sozusagen in Deutschland heißt es unter den Tisch fallen.
Gut, ich wünsche Ihnen für die Prüfung alles Gute
und seien Sie gelassen und das kriegen Sie gut hin.
Wo ist die Prüfung?
Wo ist die?
Im Badem-Müttemberg, in Erste Kammer.
Das ist Nordwürttemberg, oder Württemberg?
Ja, im Übelthemberg.
Das letzte Mal hatten wir eine Kollegin, die war in Freiburg,
hatte hier einen Bestand, hat sie mir geschrieben,
die kam aus Hotwild, glaube ich.
Ja, das ist gut.